so go ahead and fix a problem that
caused the error so here's my query to
get the conferences where I order by
name so let's just take that off we
don't want to order by name right there
instead we want to order by max
attendees we put that right after we add
the filter for it but we still want to
order by names so let's just add that
second sort order in here then you can
go ahead and test the function just make
sure that you actually have some
conferences that satisfy all these
criteria otherwise you won't get any
results so let's say you've got this
query to get all the conferences how
would you update it to filter for
conferences in Tokyo where there's at
least one but less than 10 seats
available and the results are sorted by
the number of seats available the name
of the conference and the month so when
you figured it out go ahead and enter
the code here